- NO, NO, NO.
- YES.
- HERE'S THE THING.
HERE'S THE THING.
- OKAY.
I GUARANTEE YOU.
I GUARANTEE YOU, IF YOU LOOK
AT OBAMACARE 25 YEARS FROM NOW,
AND YOU LOOK AT THE NUMBER
OF ENROLLEES IN THAT PROGRAM--
- NO, NO, NO, NO, LISTEN.
NO, YOU'VE GOT IT WRONG.
- NO, PLEASE, BY ALL MEANS,
TALK.
- YOU'VE GOT IT WRONG.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE ENROLLED
IN THE HEALTHCARE SYSTEM
AND THE TREMENDOUS EFFECT
THAT IT HAS ON THE ECONOMY.
- YOU'RE MISSING THE POINT.
- IF YOU'RE GONNA--
- YOU ARE MISSING THE POINT.
- OH, AM I?
- WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO,
WHAT YOU HAVE TO DO
IS LOOK AT THE TREMENDOUS EFFECT
THAT OBAMACARE IS HAVING
ON THE U.S. ECONOMY.
AND IN ADDITION, YOU HAVE TO
LOOK AT THE GOVERNMENT BAILOUTS
OF THE AUTO INDUSTRY
AND THE BANKING INDUSTRY.
- YOU'VE GOT IT WRONG.
YOU'VE GOT IT WRONG.
- I'VE GOT IT WRONG?
- SO WRONG.
YOU HAVE TO LOOK AT THE EFFECT
ON THE BANKING INDUSTRY
AS WELL AS THE AUTO INDUSTRY,
MY FRIEND.
- OKAY, LISTEN.
- WHEN YOU DO--
- THE BOTTOM LINE.
- NO, THE ONLY CONCLUSION...
- THE BOTTOM LINE...
both: IS THAT OBAMA
IS A DISASTER.
ARE YOU A REPUBLICAN?
YES.
- I WOULD LIKE TO APOLOGIZE
FOR THIS PROGRAMMING MISTAKE.
IN THE FUTURE, WE WILL DO BETTER
AT CHOOSING OUR GUESTS
HERE ON DIAMETRICALLY OPPOSED.